depuis le début de cette crise ont sept
la suède en dix ans ont pris un chemin
différent presque pas de confinement pas
de masque la vie continue est beaucoup
plus normalement et il sentirait plus
être dépendant des semaines on disait ça
va bien ça va mal
or on veut regarder une courbe si vous
le voulez avant de parler à anne
françoise hiver sur place d'abord les
cas ont explosé la deuxième vague est
bel et bien arrivée en suède voyez ce
graphique ça c'est les cas quotidiens et
quand on se compare aux voisins vous
allez voir qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
décès et de cas bon pour le coeur on a
1000 québec quand même pour donner une
idée qu au cumulatif par million
d'habitants depuis le début quatorze
mille sept cent soixante au québec 19000
donc la suède en a plus de cap danemark
à côté les pays scandinaves norvège et
finlande regardez la différence c'est là
le vrai comparatif avec les voisins
beaucoup plus de cas on souhaite en
suède est beaucoup plus de morts dernier
tableau 615 par million d'habitants en
suède anne françoise hiver bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste du monde
écrit encore aujourd'hui là dessus vous
êtes basé à mal mme ensuite donc alors
est ce que c est ce qu on a remis en
question totalement
là-bas le leur modèle et on recommence
et on propose aux gens un autre modèle
non non non on peut pas dire ça s'est
passé pas c'est pas la fin de la
stratégie ciolos mais il ya
effectivement un changement très
marquants depuis ces derniers jours
on avait beaucoup on s'était beaucoup
reposé sur les recommandations comme
vous le disiez au printemps peu
d'interdiction de mesures obligatoires
et là on est en train de voir
effectivement que le gouvernement durcit
le ton s'est durci et aussi les
décisions les restrictions depuis depuis
plusieurs jours et sans doute sans doute
pour plusieurs semaines
donnez moi des détails des durcissent
mal qu'est-ce qu'on ne pourra plus faire
un suède qu'on pouvait faire jusqu'à
hier oui alors pour le moment ça a
commencé aujourd'hui en fait ça prend un
peu de temps donc les annonces
l'annoncent date du 11 novembre les bars
et restaurants donc le droit de servir
de l'alcool à partir de 22 heures il
doit fermer à partir de 22h30 donc
qu'elle soit il et on n'était absolument
pas question jusqu'à présent est une
autre mesure assez importante qui a été
annoncé hier qui éclaire groupement
public ne devront pas excéder huit
personnes donc jusqu'à présent on était
à 50 personnes
on a été à 50 personnes depuis la mi
mars ces terres passer à 300 personnes
en théorie en tout cas il est à peu près
un mois sur la plupart des régions
avaient décidé d'ignorer les
recommandations du gouvernement est de
garder la limite à 50 personnes donc ça
veut dire qu'on a on allait vers dans
les faits les les théâtres les opéras
les cinémas hésite vont probablement
faire mais on a aussi un premier
ministre qui hier a bien dit clairement
en suédois que même s'il ne pouvait pas
légiférer dans la sphère privée
il fallait se tenir à la même à la même
limite même ne rencontrez plus que sa
famille si possible de ne plus aller à
la bibliothèque ne plus sortir ne plus
organiser dîner de fête etc
mais est ce que en disant ça on remet en
question les choix qui ont été faits il
ya plusieurs mois où on dit belle à la
deuxième vague est différente on agit
différemment
oui c'est plutôt ça ce que dit premier
ministre hier c'était de dire que les
recommandations avaient fonctionné au
printemps puisque on a vu que la courbe
s'infléchissent
la fin de la fin du printemps début de
l'été un peu plus tard que dans les
surtout dans les voisins nordiques mais
mais dans les pays européens en général
et que ça avait permis à la suède de
garder d un niveau de contamination très
faible pendant tout l'été même assez
longtemps pendant l'automne la deuxième
vague arriver bien plus tard que dans le
reste de l'europe
on a même cru l'itie qui aurait pas de
seconde vague et finalement on voit que
on voit qu'elle arrive donc le premier
8,6 et que ça fonctionnait au printemps
mais que ça ne fonctionne plus qu'il ya
un relâchement et donc qu'il faut il
faut agir il faut agir vite pour éviter
de revoir des chiffres comme on en a vu
empruntant ou même même bien pire
mais vous dites ça fonctionnait mais
n'empêche on va envoyer les tableaux il
y a par rapport aux pays scandinaves
il ya beaucoup plus de cas et de morts
quand même ça fonctionnait ça
fonctionnait c'est ce que dit le
gouvernement en tout cas les gens
avaient changé de comportement donc ont
estimé qu'il n'y avait pas besoin de
d'un confinement qu'on a comme on a pu
le l'instaurer dans les autres pays en
europe après est ce qu'on a réussi à
protéger les personnes les personnes
âgées notamment les personnes les
groupes à risque non ça a été une
catastrophe dans les maisons de retraite
et c'est un peu la raison d'ailleurs
pour laquelle on voit un durcissement
actuellement c'est que les
contaminations sont en train de
reprendre dans la maison de retraite
alors qu'on nous avait promis que les
choses avaient changé on allait bien
mieux préparée à l'automne et on voit
que ce n'est pas le cas et d'où la
crainte d'une augmentation des
hospitalisations qui est qui est déjà
notable actuellement et puis des décès
dans les semaines qui viennent
parlez moi du match parce que il n'y a
pas on a vu les photos tout à l'heure de
jeu passée tu es stockholm on peut
importe les gens ne portent pas le
masque en suède les gens ne portent pas
le masque sas et c'est assez
extraordinaire parce que non seulement
le port du masque n'est pas obligatoire
donc on compare ce qui n'est pas le cas
dans la
la totalité des pays urbain mais il
n'est même pas recommandé c'est à dire
que les autorités sanitaires l' agence
de la santé publique qui qui qui
vraiment oui qui dirige un peu la
stratégie cieux l'aise qui est qui et
qui l'a mise en place ne le recommande
pas pour plusieurs raisons donc d'une
part parce que du point de vue des
experts de l'agencé de la santé publique
suédoise les études scientifiques ne
sont pas assez convaincante sur les
faits du masque contre les
contaminations mais d'autre part ils
craignent que l'imposé notamment dans
des situations comme les transports en
commun au travail etc
il risquerait de réduire l'incitation en
fait à respecter la distance physique et
donc avoir un effet un effet nul ou même
empirer les contaminations sont donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle on ne le
on ne nous le recommande pas mais il y a
actuellement un débat qui est en train
de monter donc à voir comment comment
les choses vont évoluer les prochains
jours intéressant
ça nous rappelle nous on nous donnait
ses arguments au tout début aussi la
santé publique au québec en trop disait
c'est pas prouvée puis le mas a peut
être dangereux les gens vont s'approcher
trop ne respecteront plus la barrière
des deux maîtres de maîtres chez nous on
va suivre ça avec beaucoup d'intérêt
anne-françoise hiver je rappelle journée
pour le monde vous êtes basé en suède
merci de nous avoir parlé merci